tito le titan vidéo tito va au marché de
guillaume bernardin aux éditions ti baba
les collections de la réunion tito est
un petit ans qui habite dans les hauts
de l'île de la réunion
au milieu de magnifiques montagnes il
aime laventure et rêve de découvrir le
monde
aujourd'hui maman va au marché
tu veux venir avec moi demande maman oh
oui
infantino il ya beaucoup de monde
surtout ne lâche pas ma main dis maman
il ne faut pas se perdre c'est vous qui
cultive et vos légumes demande si tôt
oui et en plus je ne met aucun produit
c'est meilleur pour la nature et pour
nous répond le marchand il veut des
samoussas demande un commerçant moi moi
répond tito dit maman je peux aller en
prendre oui tito prend en 2 1 pour toi
et un pour moi quelle bonne odeur j'ai
eu une bonne idée
c'est dit tito maman va être contente
mais où est maman maman maman criscito
maman un disparu
tito est perdu sitôt cherche partout
mais il ya bien trop de monde
il ne trouve pas sa maman qu'il se met à
pleurer
sitôt regarde le commerçant en pleurant
j'ai perdu ma maman dit tito je suis là
dit maman je prenais des légumes
derrière toi je ne lâcherai plus ta main
dit sitôt je ne veux plus de perdre
tiens maman ils sont très bons c'est
samoussas et c'est moi qui les ai
achetés